look at us right now I don't know no you
look like [ __ ] good day son I do declare
[Laughter]
[Music]
broccolini get your life together
[Music]
breathing a monk fruit huh
I think a monkey oh yes everybody hears
on different sweeteners we're gonna dang
9-ball do it and I'll get on the same
page see you talkin about the devil's
dandruff we done with the Lord's table
or dandruff is Steve thought they've
caught Steve really get that Steve Hemi
a Steve what is it it's it's a ground-up
leaf that gives you extra sweet teeth
that's cocaine dude oh dude you gotta
get some cocaine boy take some weight
off your head will be smaller dog I'll
get that stuff that'll take some weight
off you and I be like glob City with
these nose pasa from there this
[ __ ]
the Vince Carter man I love DeAndre
Hopkins on the end of that ya know
cookie you know for me oh come on dude
hey Nick you ever done coke couple times
[Laughter]
Nick was a couple of it Nick loses a
couple of bets a few years they go
online and he does construction in
Wisconsin the rough goes good trust me
if Anderson Silva didn't fight back
[ __ ] I told you should have seen
his bats man he might you might have to
start your own betting site you see his
bats this week God did he said to my
like dude you got a gift did he do it we
want oven thousand dollars oh why did
you do this parlay how dare you
now he'll get me dude now that women
know he has money but hey one 7j man
they were going after Bieber nothing
after Nick yeah that's the one to go
after yeah he did that good ass pigs
Nick yeah that's crazy man
dude oh how was Vegas you surprise your
boy Dustin Poirier oh yeah it was cool
it was exciting man he got home just
kind of surprised was just like a small
party it is at some place that he was
staying at a just walked in like he'd
just been it like a long day at the
office Connie you know it was a long 25
minutes
yeah puts his keys on the counter I did
I did well because I was a close fight
man oh it was crazy you could see how at
the end he was just like come on I know
I did enough to get it done you know I
do the practice I told Nick you and I
had it too - going to the fifth and then
he pulled that fifth out at the end but
it was you with those judges you never
know man I'll say I could see them maybe
get to hook her but doesn't should have
won yeah yeah I think it would have been
hard if they gave it to if they would
have given it to him they've definitely
but he giving it to her
the judges have definitely done worse
you don't really know dude so [ __ ]
would have got that they would have done
even and look I mean hooker I thought I
think it was a great fight I think
fighter Yuri had more experience in
those later rounds and hooker just got
gassed I think on the ground I don't
know but the best that's what poor he
does like my boy was like I think I'm
take cooker because you know his knees
and he puts big money I thought about
these two and then he's like the knees
he's just dangerous and the team he
trained through it and Dustin's been out
for a while
he got so Dustin kind of gassed isn't
like whoa oh no he doesn't
he'd be just engag you look in his
fights with Eddie Alvarez you just fight
you know you even compete he does not
gasp I'm fine it's better over time
you got that third long man I think he's
got the third line Louisiana lone get
that Louisiana saying it's got some
water in it but it holds everybody
so I don't know it was this exciting man
I think it was like his wife and just
some another couple and then two buddies
at his and then was he pretty beat up
yeah he's pretty beat up one of his eyes
the right eye was kind of closed up and
was like can you see out of him he's
like you know he's like I couldn't pick
anybody out of a lion out of a policeman
was his daughter there no the kid I
wasn't there but he was oh and then we
sat and watched the fight with him so
that was cool because then we got to
watch it all like really enjoy it
you know um but yeah man he just yeah I
don't know you know what there's
something about him that makes him so
fun and cheer for two you know I don't
know what was a good guy yeah I think
that I mean I know that's what it is but
he just that's right cheer for him yeah
he just like he's also paid his dues
like you know people love Oh Marvin all
because you know the dudes been fine
since he's 17 or 14 the backyard poor a
very similar dude yeah can't go back to
poor and he's a young dude fighting men
yeah he's paid his dues did he beat two
Michael Vick's dogs dude and those dogs
that lost they electrocute him and
drowned yeah yeah that he did that dude
had a 500 million dollar contract was
with Nike was killing dogs at his
off-time day you know dude I don't know
watching these fights when YouTube first
came out oh dude they Kimbo stuff yeah
early is like you talking life-changing
uh-huh
that [ __ ] was unbelievable I would give
a whole new vibe for a backyard it used
to be a place you were considered having
a pool and out some sponsors on the
grass yes hey uh dad mow a monster in
the yard we need some damn choline
hey let's do like the UFC uh yeah most a
monster no long then don't pay the guys
let's keep all the money I know man I
hope that [ __ ] starts to change for
those guys they go too hard man yeah
Jared doesn't is a good dude yeah yeah
it's fun man it was funny all that time
off that he had and just me a big fight
next
cuz coke is five bori was the ranked
number three
yeah well I think he I mean I think he
just waits until he gets a real fact
that he really wants but then he well
he'll get a big fight cuz you're right
three just reached number five you look
at the lineup I could see him versus
Connor coming back yeah that would be a
mega fight well Connor needs to come
back there to shut the [ __ ] up or just
retired huh
I mean I mean he never will it kind of
makes a movie would you say that I just
laughed at the [ __ ] yeah dude I'll
[ __ ] fight Connor do do beat me
remember 145 no dude you'll beat me bro
but I'll fight him in Scotland dude you
know oh yeah okay
all right glasses that Scottish tap
water dog I'll [ __ ] go at least half
around get that proper deal go oh yeah
get that proper for baby I think I
started selling improper ate that's
funny whiskey improper 8-ball how much
we're paying Chapelle but look at that
bling-bling my barbecue joint going like
god I have to change yeah I gotta have a
chain dan you look at that guy's goal on
my watch really yeah he'll probably die
then Trinidad James turn down her neck
James was it good yeah ever since yeah
the barbecue company like is becoming a
thought in my mind you know I feel like
I got to change my your living you know
I got the feeling well put a bomb on
that [ __ ] hang a pig femur off that
sucker so I go get a gold ribbon yeah
live a little man doing nothing man
start start flexing the barbecue nuts on
these hoes hang a hog hip off that [ __ ]
burger put a [ __ ] you know put a baby
lamb clavicle on this okay get old yam
up in the
introduce you some real black faux gold
yeah that cell is rate move I'm Sonic oh
yeah and all it go into you happy fourth
of July though huh
now it's gonna hurt a little bit because
there's no fireworks allowed in Los
Angeles serious no they banned all
fireworks in beaches oh the people in LA
park beg to differ donor so I was just
so for this worth like July just gotta
close your eyes and imagine you do have
people send off fireworks yeah like
crazy I'm Haley I love it oh you like it
I think my guns up when I was growing up
the big thing is to be fill your trunk
with firecrackers you know yeah and talk
about those real hitters though like the
black hats of ammonium m16 tm5 did you
know maybe even in that sins you know
just Mexican due to the trunk what the
goal would be you'd load as many as you
could have your trunk and light it throw
a match in there and then you would just
drive down the street with that thing
just said yeah and sometime they would
put it then they would stick the bottle
rockets over by the gas tanks I feel
like the bad there's two there's two
there's two come on now
that's what's been reacting that down
those are the smallest and where'd you
get these these little baby ones thank
you for children man I feel like there's
more dangerous than the regular adult
ones because they're so small well
that's America guys that's 2020 we're
trying to do something nice for Ian you
complain about it so you try to get
cancelled yeah yeah which I get your
girl cancelled on Twitter no oh there's
small sparkle Nick over
what the [ __ ] is he doing this not very
nice of you dude yeah that's good work
everybody - don't you a soffit m80 in
this [ __ ] and almost a run broke you
through a pack of those wrinkles are not
do you know what I couldn't stop thing
about last night that's where my life is
that think how you know those little
poppers those little things kids playing
yeah someone's job is filling a little
bag and twist it and put it oh yeah
that's gonna be probably somebody that's
in recovery I bet you know right so we
made some bad life decisions yeah
somebody's bought a gram and hid it in
their body probably yeah but think you
think I made those of those little ball
that would take someone to do just one
pack they have a hundred thousand okay
wonder what they make is that can you
pull up a pack of it I don't oh yeah
yeah we get done with that iPhone
they're going straight to the
firecrackers Wow because China still
goes hard in the paint on firecrackers
it's like that's what they do
bang snaps they call banks which is also
I believe a Taiwanese name my next
girlfriend either said Banyan also known
as a little boy toys - let me see these
names on this stuff also as the
throwdowns also known as snap it
stoppers black pops poppies poppets
cherry poppers whipper snapper t snap
fun snaps yeah whiz bang her booty
putters yes by the end you're just in
Pittsburgh you just pull up a
these things and you can buy those
things anyone I'm fine oh you can get
those things in Louisiana at a parade
now here you can get them at at a Mardi
Gras parade they sell them you go out
real quick real quick just because I
wanna see what's in these things bang
snaps consists of a small amount of grab
gunpowder and coarse sand impregnated
with a minut quantity of silver
fulminate high explosive and twisted in
cigarette paper to produce a shape
resembling a cherry oh wow praise God
yeah that [ __ ] sounds fantastic look at
just oh they're also part of a common
Chinese New Year celebration ahh
do they have um did you guys have these
at home and stuff when you're growing up
Chan right
really well I had those now you never
have these two MiG's they're not real
Asian people love fireworks don't think
it's what they do have you ever seen
that shite like a real Chinese fireworks
show I mean they make art and that's two
dragons heightened yeah like oh yeah
yeah there's gonna be dude [ __ ] man
they're all yeah oh dude don't have a
damn don't shoot it it'll be like a
diner rickshaw eating a damn dumpling
you know balancing on a step and it's
all made out of Lights infused you know
cream every other Korean barbecue just
have a light dude some people they send
humans up there with just a candle and
then to take their own life once her in
the air junior girl who puts on her
firework show where does she get all of
them there's what there's always those
spots yeah as a kid growing up is
Wyoming for me well you guys go to
Wyoming
yeah really how it because they're
illegal they're all everything you could
get the Disney [ __ ] fireworks they're
the ones I set off at Disneyland in like
nine the ones that [ __ ] shooting yeah
yeah oh yeah and we we didn't know you
need to shoot on a tube so we lit it in
my neighborhood thought it would just
fly in the sky
equipment that [ __ ] whoa what hit every
house Jinju go fishing this weekend to
blow some fish up well how would you get
what you got a baby bath that's the same
one from last week you sugarbabyz the
catch on this time just you and your
girl yeah
they don't stay out there oh what'd you
bake for dinner at night packs who as
for packs are good man what's a foil
pack Popo dinners yeah fire down he set
it on there my sister oh man I'm good I
like a little burnt foil brah
you have to take a [ __ ] in the woods Jim
yeah ask him how he can't send ask him
how they build a tent or where do they
build its have an awesome tent it's just
a pop-up calling pop-ups you just take
it on the bag throw it out it's good to
go
there's a David Blaine of 10 it's the
best it's but you don't don't worry
about making a tent was two stories or
what it fits for people and just the two
you can yeah
Wow it's extra room extra you wake up
early a [ __ ] though I always wake up
around 7:00
Wow because I want to go fishing yeah I
love goin fishing man yeah so what's the
closest spot I could go fishing you
think to LA you think probably the one
of the place I went to last time is Lake
Cachuma it so I'm like two two hours
maybe but it's like a legit lake take
your ass to [ __ ] the Venice canals
Venice Beach yeah
have catch afraid up hold it yeah catch
some prostitute in the water just
[ __ ] polio that's a pretty Lake huh
where's that at chin it said I guess
this close to Santa Barbara so it's
quite sad about our son he said the
clothes stuff from Ellie though it's not
that bad about two hours yeah pretty
close Big Bear is also good but it's not
like it's any other direction dude take
your [ __ ] ass to the ocean bro we're
right up the street
but that ocean around the edge is just
all people you can't even catch a few
turds you thought those back in the
water I'm not people did I catch a turd
price and pay
I ain't catching no turn ass you never
know what you're gonna get out there huh
you never know what you're gonna get
well I'm young surfer you become friends
with you know I'll catch a friend that's
good catch feelings yeah I'll catch
feelings is the bag of feelings no Casey
did I tell you what man I haven't been
feeling great and I was like my doctor
goes you need hydration you gotta really
hydrated I went all right while trying
guzzle all the water I can No
and then I went in my closet dude and I
noticed I had that little freakin tasty
liquid IV it boosts my immunity I sleep
better with it and your did you put on
the kitchen counter man I know I forget
I've gotta lean you about no and liquid
IV it's the number one thing man each
serving helps you get as much hydration
as two to three bottles of water and I'm
dehydrated dude that's one of the routes
I don't feel good I come off the road
when you're flying you know that dry
year so right when I get home I pop that
liquid IV man I feel instantly better it
has five essential vitamins more vitamin
C than an orange and as much potassium
as a banana
yep it's made with clean ingredients
non-gmo vegan free of gluten dairy and
soy and it has cellular transport
technology that's what makes liquid IV
so effective and I'll say this there are
other powders out there that you add in
the water to get hydration the other
ones that I found their clunky they
don't that's what dissolves these I
knows in that I was like think I've done
up with it for ill side to look like
yeah it's easy and you can feel it
hydrating too you can feel your cells
being like it's a party it's a party
it's a party
look what Ivey is available nationwide
at Costco or you can get 25% off when
you go to liquid IV calm and use code k
ATS at checkout that's 25% off anything
you order when you use the Cote ATS at
liquid I be calm get better hydration
today at liquid IV calm promo code k 80s
get thirsty stay quenched baby out there
right now film it's hard to get to the
gym dude it's hard to get to the gym
I've been lifting weights for years so
it's been hard for me to find the right
workout I don't want to go to the gym so
I'm looking for a new program or
something like that and somebody said yo
fake boy how about you get a fit Babu
and did you get one still looking for
that mmm but I'm taking steps in the
right direction with fit bod it's a
smart fitness app that takes all the
guesswork out of planning your workouts
fit bods algorithm factors in your goals
experience level equipment workout
duration and muscle recovery to
intelligently craft the perfect total
body workout program just for you - oh I
know what you're talking about you're
talking about the app yeah yeah dawg one
thing I love about Fit bods app is that
you can pick whatever workouts you can
tailor them to your equipment and your
goals so if you have certain equipment
at home then you can pick workouts that
that utilize your equipment oh you're
doing junk just your glutes like feel
just once you just as glutes
alright it's gonna let you know you need
to be fully recover your network out you
can pick what body part you want to work
muscle groups alright yep and it can
even chart things out so it balances
muscle groups so that you know by the
time you you you work something out and
the next time you do it on the schedule
your muscles are already revived
ok bros quit working out that ass Fit
Body helps everyone work out every
muscle group without overworking any of
oh I need a playa bro
I need ass in my biceps yeah Doug get a
personalized fitness plan now that helps
you work out smarter at fit bod
Emme / k 80s so I fit bought for free
for one month when you sign up at fit
bought me / Kate
yes that's right it's personalized
training it sits on a budget fit bot is
only $9.99 a month or $59.99 a year and
it's free for one month again when you
sign up at Fit Body Emmy /k ATS yeah man
go to the website get a program tailored
to your unique body and whatever workout
you're looking for fit Bob works out our
balance to avoid overworking muscles
with a variety excited to keep you in
shape
you don't need gym equipment man they
got it all go to the website to sign up
now right go to the website try fit Bob
for free for one month when you sign up
online at Fit Body Emmy /k ATS y'all do
cocaine out there too no copay my
crinkle game you mean [ __ ] did you do
any drugs to y'all doing out we bought
this whole huge handle of Jameson though
we know the big plastic one though
you're a girl be getting sauce it's not
even plastic things girl be getting
saucy we got this is it right here oh
snap oh you guys are cute you guys are
cute that's one dangerous so that's one
dangerous thing about a foil packs nice
and cool oh you sure is that a coal in
it yeah you grab you know you grab what
the tongs and put on the table sometimes
you grab a coal with it wow yeah damnit
chin trying to make sure everything's
all right look at you guys in matching
glasses girl corn porn do you say bite
that car girl yeah damn that's just
romantic l can't even imagine
don't let hot Carl see this she can be
pissed the way you treat your girl Ken
eaten both
just continue eating what is that a beer
right there what is it to Wycoff
what is it why can we get loose man how
the drinking huh Jameson yeah does she
know how you get if you have a bunch of
sake
that's dark wine remember with hot Carli
had a bunch of soccer tits yeah you had
a bunch he was divorced at the time bro
daddy getting bent out out there damn
you guys a real couple I thought you
were lying the wood will represent a
king in the stare low usually real
frustrate their fire the kid hoodie you
need a link pop it up right eye on those
fish fry jumped in the boat leaking all
swaggy we got one we got one down the
fish bro did you um no where'd y'all get
that boat you rented it yeah we rendered
it Wow
it's a side console so for the whole day
it's like 168 and is there um is there
catfish in that lake - no there's really
yeah I get jump in the water chin like
our girl Hannah I get your [ __ ] go
get knuckle deep in these stupid fish I
mean I wish it was like that dude
they're like really hard to get over
here yeah what are the fish yeah the
fish especially now cuz the covert stuff
they don't tell you when they're
stalking the lake so these are planted
leeks you know there's no it's not a
natural lake they stop come on yeah yeah
was there a lot of people out there no
wow it was actually pretty good straight
chin you're there all goddamn day you
only cut that baby bath yeah no she
taught the baby a sheik I got the baby
bass here she caught the baby bass in
Big Bear and Big Bear was so packed you
don't want to go there right now yeah
yeah you can even get a boat we got
lucky someone cancelled this video ends
in asked for a credit card number
a wasp paywall Oh for pay more than only
fans huh then get our feet out in the
tan ugh I got lonely fans dude
patreon.com slash Theo von thick bands
only calm this one watch me eat you toy
with shoes the Instagram girl she only
ate [ __ ] with a flaming hot cheetos
where that big girl
she's like crunch up all the flamin hot
cheetos and like roll corn on the cob
and it what she liked me spaghetti
eating in front of the camera oh yeah I
thought about this years ago if they had
a video of just a hot girl eatin yeah
they're doing it bro just like watching
somebody is to eat like regular eat oh
it's only girls I mean it could be guys
too although I would demand to watch
dudes eat like hot dogs and watches a
guy I'd be watching through oh you watch
it yeah one of my favorite is bending
bending bending heal is he like a Korean
American guy what's he what's he making
like top ramen and [ __ ] he does Korean
food he does like regular food at times
you like to watch him eat there's like
there's a video where he goes like uh
like on a water diet for two weeks or
something and then eats like this really
expensive steak it's just a John Cusack
a little if John Cusack was Korean yeah
like old school newspapers and socialism
eating this giant sometimes Katniss
girlfriend in the background - dude
named Devils good stuff so freaking this
thing I'm just eating in front of a
camera or just you doing only fans of
you only fans and you were just like a
big old cheeseburger
yeah because I kind of navigate your way
through yeah make your hands look
smaller and post or no food bratwurst
that [ __ ] yeah picking up a goat on the
same end like this
two hands on the same man like a
baseball bat yeah a Dodger cat takes
down a Dodger yeah dog yeah you know
trick you in the title you feel me I
feel you dude but I want to know if
you've done cocaine what do you think if
I've done it or not I think that you
seem like a guy who's definitely done
somebody don't you jumped in the gt-r
once or twice and did a bunch of coke
not a GTR I know it was rift Nathan Ford
what does that call know in a civic ass
Bronco no never in a car unless your
partner are I think we have 90 minutes
of audio of chin and Carly eating Korean
barbecue and 75% was them talking about
cocaine in the entire time unheard
that's patriarchy on tit so Dan so chin
breaks out that cocaine chatter cat have
you ever done cocaine no you been around
it
yes I've never really even seen it we
got to get some we can get some in you
would like that can we legally have some
in here or not
no nobody notes cocaine what if it
subscribe to someone we could say we
could say it stevia yeah do I go let's
try out different artificial flavors
yeah but this one your sniff dude I've
watched some of y'all do a little bit of
cocaine and I couldn't be here as like
the lifeguard kind of yeah like the
buddy you know you could be like our
coaching coach yeah your CC coach coach
gang all right let's do some jumping
jacks all right your heart rates can go
through the roof you start sweating
you'll be all right now
you'll be fine man yeah just get a
couple of American spirits and get out
on the patio
is there some level and make sure it's
fun for sake okay dude I'll tell you
like about a year ago I was doing some
television project thing and they had
fake cocaine on the set and I did about
six lines over I bet you did because I
forget what they cuz I mean Brian do the
thing for fine kid 3d where we got
addicted to cocaine and so that fake
cocaine dollar cuz we had stuff to sniff
and it was like a bunch of like ground
up like be something yeah be 12 yeah
yeah that's what I did it was bad if
that yeah if the ton of it all through
the day and uh can't be healthy after a
certain amount I didn't mind it it
doesn't give you a real buzz it kind of
keeps you up though keep you excited I
guess about the afternoon to get you
through another chapter of a book if
you're gonna say if I'm skilled like is
a ver all close to cocaine I've done the
Hatter all I don't know you gotta mix
definitely done it nice on it big fan
you [ __ ] with it I'll do about nine
milligrams a day okay oh so you're an
addict that's cool I mean addicts go
sixty ninety they get crazy antics on
100x get up there man I think milligrams
is pret almost perfect maybe huh I do
laughing a little too much boy yeah I do
[Laughter]
not you know my origins I'm sorry look
you guys are the little posses that are
hanging out with Rick is Stevie all day
man yes so use it every day yeah less
than a prescription not on weekends and
stuff but yeah I've always thought I had
a DD I think a DD is over prescribed for
like children and stuff but like I'll
read a book for like a half hour I'll be
thirty pages deep it'll be I didn't I
was thinking about something else if I'm
an adderall I'm very effective so yeah
you sound like you're trying to convince
us
now raises either I need to talk to
someone but no no I mean chin uses
kratom every single day now I use it I
would say five out of seven days and we
still use create them twice on Sunday
what you still use creative oh yeah Wow
you use it every day Jen
yeah and it's a completely opposite than
adderall it like chills me out okay yeah
not me it helps my brain
yeah dang well really helps my brain no
no if I can go an extra scoop then do
you really welp it's time baby time look
is fourth of July baby time to get that
D working maybe you know what I'm saying
trying to get that put a little bit of
thinking in your Lincoln bro yeah a
little thinking your Lincoln but also
don't worry about losing your hair
anymore either man we're worried about
enough stuff in this about our hearing
know you're here dude oh yeah yeah dude
check out our here unite we we don't
have to be worried about it
yeah Ames bro 66% of men start loser
here by 35
I got hair on my back and ass man thanks
Sims yeah Dahlia stuff scroll down your
back you got that duck tail some dude
you could look man I'll brow get a girl
to corner on my back at the beach in
Jamaica you get them dreads hanging up
your ass cheeks oh yeah four hams calm a
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for the bros it's time
to write a new chapter one in which you
have hair bro that's right take care of
your hair you want oh you want for hims
cuz it connects you to real doctors
online and that can save you hours
they're going in and waiting in a
waiting room or hiding somewhere waiting
for a doctor to come and find you yeah
it's completely confidential
it's disagree toward I scream answer a
few questions a doctor will review and
if they determine it's right for you can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that has shipped directly to your
door no more being at the wall green or
something sneaking around and having to
look at the stuff that hair supplies
everybody making fun of you yeah oh look
at him look at it look at Carl yeah I
get real hairy right now you guys can
get a first month free when you go to
for hims calm /ke 80s that's for him
calm /ke 80s right prescription requires
an online consultation with a medical
provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate offer valid only if
prescribed three months minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply
see website full details and important
safety information remember that's for
hem is calm / kts get damn grill and
grill up some [ __ ] crazy and play I
know I was looking at smokers yeah cuz
you guys got me thinking dude start with
that baby bad start regional brother
semi regional start with just baby back
ribs
[ __ ] I was looking up brisket - well now
you getting fancy yeah you need a real
smoker for the brisket the ribs we can
get down ribs you could do in your
living room yeah okay ribs you get doing
the ground ok someone on Twitter said
that they're getting rid of Aunt Jemima
and replacing her with chef PO oh nice
habanero pineapple barbecue sauce yeah
yeah baby yeah people were hitting me up
hey I can help you make a sauce yeah
chef yeah sure smoky lava brah yes sweet
smoky lava or just smoky lava yeah
there's people coming up with names be
careful with the dudes you actually I
could contribute to your sauce yeah Jeff
fells milky showdown you call one of my
milky that milky showdown whatever that
cream based [ __ ] sauce baby dude
Chappelle's milky showdown chef pal come
get his lava now tell me twice till we
were to put my lava we only party and
you sell it by the gallon only none of
this small bat no small batches for
[ __ ] yeah yeah he's a real big [ __ ]
man yeah chef pills big batch Joe
chapell it'll last him long enough man
they can keep it in the outside fridge
they probably can keep it inside yeah
I'll talk about like expiration huh
that's not your concern
man how fast they eat is up to now you
think masterpiece barbecues worry about
how fast you use their sauce start
thinking bro you think they sent us
somebody uh some sauce census to your
house
dude okay yeah it's funny chicken Co
massage you've aged
don't be ridiculous yeah yeah how old
are you my sauce weird do the name
someone came up with for my sauces away
sauce I like Chappelle's sweet lover or
chappelle's lava backflip in barbecue
racial slur though I think isn't it is
it flip means Filipino I think doesn't
look at all so you tell me that's better
than smoking Lacey's smoking Lacey's
come on bro smoking Lacey's it probably
people what if kids start smoking when
they see it they're like oh I want
cigarettes with this well that's on them
well well we don't like some fat kid
might as you know you're out of a job
sauce ideas that spicy hitter right on
the chin
big brown barbecue catsup Wisconsin okay
this is if everybody on King in the
sting had their own sauce some of the
nice some of the names Oh a sauce is
champion but then what you just read
that spicy eater right on the chin right
on the chin big brown barbecue I missed
a little too on the nose
yeah a little on the nose man this
person could have thought a little
longer better cats yeah do the
description for Wisconsin betters it was
a case yeah Nick my job gang gang
barbecue stunts
good job and he's a good dude yes he
took ten grams of that here's a guy
right here who's a white guy was
probably willing to give up his identity
and everything so people online will
hear some guy who's gonna donate some
cream deer sauce what do you got I got a
debate club for you since Chappell
didn't sound too interested in the
barbecue collab agree which I rather
have Chappelle's
Thicke boy nation BB Q or Chin's
hot spicy
Korean bvq let me know what you think
gang gang but [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah come on
so basically he's asking if it's
barbecue or a Korean barbecue listen man
I know where you're at on this game
there is nothing better than American
barbecue you go down the truth of July
every day yeah there's nothing better
than a nice [ __ ] full rack of ribs or
some brisket some nice corn bread
it's all in the sauce bro it's all in
the sauce you got a good sweet barbecue
sauce a little Hickory so without
Carolina yet I can make it just is the
other thing now you guys know yeah yeah
do you like it wet you like to get wet
dog or do you like a dry rub you gotta
think about what you're doing Chappelle
it's got a lot of [ __ ] work to do
dude gotta lay some [ __ ] [ __ ] you
bought wonderful you bought one gold
chain actually I didn't buy this my
girlfriend uh actually took it from her
[Laughter]
Nicki Minaj little Kim little Kim
believes in pigeons dude I'm telling you
man yeah you got to get something going
broker you're wasting time and whatever
you know what we're doing wasting ideas
got a great business plan that someone
right now is probably putting [ __ ]
together
I'm 16 I'm gonna walk out here and it's
[ __ ] smoking Lacey's barbecue and
you're like oh what the [ __ ]
first of all y'all don't know what I'm
doing at home yeah you told us you
hadn't been doing this from the giant
yeah you're right sir my bad double
you're doing good man let's see with
this girl wait you didn't answer so what
you love most at American barbecue right
oh yeah barbecue yeah I go American Bar
we have a crew in barbecue just because
I think if I go to Korea or I go to a
Korean place that I want Korean barbecue
you know but on the holiday I think I
want American barbecue
I want American barbecue 24/7 7 days a
week yeah if it's good Oh bro
I'll take that innum dude brothers
barbecue in Denver Colorado needs to
English brothers who went around all
Texas and Oklahoma was like oh these are
good ideas store all their [ __ ] come out
white people do with black people
culture store
American culture dish so all these black
people you know all the barbecue ideas
and create their best called brothers
barbecue blind people still white
culture to the luck going to the library
you've seen a black guy at the library I
go to the library there you got a fair
point Brit library is a very British
system I think mm-hmm
might be Greek actually shot two
brothers barbecue though is it good Wow
the best what do you think cat I would
usually say Korean barbecue but if you
have cornbread I'm always gonna go for
American barbecue mmm cobbler I will
know that is cornbread in general I'm
going nuts man I'm riled up because
Chappelle we need to get your [ __ ]
business started cuz the other thing
he's not gonna do it all those people
out a chain all those people so those
people eat their barbecue they want to
wash it down with a nice dessert so
you're gonna have to have peach cobbler
you have to have a banana custard maybe
it's not having entree yet Brendan yeah
right he doesn't have a business model
he doesn't even have a frickin JPEG or
anything yeah logo yeah he doesn't even
want to do it I don't think we thought
maybe we should do our own huh well we
can get a food truck and makes your
pouch FL drive it yeah do you have a
commercial driver's license CDL Wow I
could do whatever yeah I'll put that on
to well America man let's say something
nice about it guys well let's see what
this lady has to say first she's been
waiting kratom Queen sup Brendan Amanda
from Sacramento and I have a debate clip
for you guys been spending a lot of time
in quarantine a lot of time at home
watching TV and it reminds me of those
days when I was a kid from school just
so I could stay home and watch The Price
is Right so who do you guys think is the
better host is it drew Carey or that og
Bob Barker let me know what you guys
think debated I want to hear your
thoughts
love you guys gang gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz you know we had a you know to
score and four years ago we had a dog in
our neighborhood they call it Bob Barker
because it was always real my Ombuds and
a freeze boom and he stopped barking oh
yeah shut down he shut it down Bob
Barker's the real gangster [ __ ] both
these boys I would hurry up home and
watch a Jerry Springer
really oh dude a spring or was on about
3 p.m. get them school at 2:00 I brush
on watch Jerry Springer Wow
why for the violence you think that's
probably that's early UFC really it
really was you know I love Jerry
Springer man as much what I thought it
was real oh oh nothing like it man yeah
and then he always left you with a good
like yeah final thought Jerry's final
thought
thank you notice bouncer Steve Jerry's
final thought dude I saw him at the
beach one time in San Diego was I saw
him walking with his daughter or some
meaty meaty girl oh I forgot to tell you
when I was in Laguna real meat sticks
something you'd thrown on the grill when
I was in Laguna I saw your boy the
pastor you did yeah Earl Lance yeah it's
your boy was my boy but you introduced
me to him yeah great guy but remember I
was joking around calm the [ __ ] boy to
Jesus yeah yeah you shouldn't have done
it
talk to him yeah yeah good looking dude
man
Carl yeah I mean he's okay I mean he's
handsome but um I wouldn't say he's
good-looking God but I'm not gonna say
it up that was him we had a little
conversation
oh yeah Carl's awesome man I love Carl
dude yeah he's super nice yeah they got
a tiger game a high five pastor named
Judah was really good buddy of his yeah
I know judo he do yep I don't do that
Church in here they're in he's in
Seattle I think or like Portland right
Church home is the church that they do
here that's on Wednesday nights on
Wilshire but I think it hasn't been open
because of kovat the disease you know
you know where churches at Chabot I have
in your
brother yeah okay Jesus Christ never
leaves you get over there man
mm-hmm don't know you you walk-in man I
had time for that chain they'll think
you come straight out the Bible sir out
of Egypt bro you wear that neck piece
I'll be like dang this guy's right out
of chapter six right here they'll love
you I tiger give a carl in - high five -
[ __ ] give him some fist no I was like
God dude no and I said you know
hopefully you don't think they said if
he's like not me you guys are great dude
oh good that's it thanks dude please
don't tell the big man upstairs yeah
he's a cool guy man I love Carl yeah I
do I like both him and Judah yeah but uh
hey listen with Drew Carey to me it's a
little bit of a cop-out I get he's
making [ __ ] Bank but doing that job
everyday kind of selling your soul to
the devil man because he was a gangster
remember he did whose line is there
anyways he was a big comic kiddush his
show that was based you know drew Carey
show he was killing it when you do this
you just selling your soul man yeah no
one's watching really anymore oh come on
down wait baby watch people are watching
I used to get Nick look at the raving
stop ain't nobody watched that [ __ ]
no look I used to get sick just to stay
home and watch it what come on at 10:00
a.m. and that came on it meant that you
were skipping school yeah you were
living life mom was at work or doing
some [ __ ] dead-end job that she'd
scored and you had a chance at millions
of dollars even though you really did it
all the time I'm sorry mom I would fake
like I was sick in my mom would drop me
off at my grandma's yeah and then I'll
just watch to you I'd watch SportsCenter
all day but then flip back the [ __ ]
price is right you know yeah I'm more
tennis and [ __ ] prices right and I
just couldn't wait for that Jerry
Springer to hit that was a mare
bro no [ __ ] living 2020 yeah I know what
the fight is look at us right now I
don't know you look like [ __ ] good day
son I do declare dude any other
different types that like if you would
do that it just meant like gotta go you
know no but if you did that a minute I'm
gonna be here for a while and if you did
this to me that means got a little sugar
at home sex talk about Steve that's real
that's not that bipartisanship yesterday
what did you guys watch when you would
skip school cat I was never allowed to
skip school I was never allowed to call
out sick even if I was sick none of us
are allowed to do it no no my mom would
force me to go to school regardless of
what's happening bomb threats you go to
school you have the swine flu you go to
school still got you ask me the night
before you go to school that's not fun
yeah and that's probably why cope now it
means you're a complete [ __ ]
yeah I'm not yeah yeah yeah that's true
it's really really true think about all
the things Asia did in America railroad
build the railroads a lot of it under
forced labor
semi forced I think martial arts martial
art ghouls Tech one dose schools
everywhere Bruce Lee yeah but the karate
school dude growing up if yeah if you
were that kid they would took karate
school that was not cool when I was
young they're like oh dude Jason knows
karate it would always be like let's
fight him punch punch and punch oh dude
if anybody went to grotty that was the
first verse through everybody yeah I
beat there hey I get news where it's
still not cool bro well I think it
changed over to MMA so I think if you
know both of the skills it's probably
like you know if you know jujitsu ink
[ __ ] no matter what you're doing
really doesn't help it's like the
coronavirus of like of skilled martial
arts yeah yeah it's [ __ ] and
nobody's gonna die
using it and you guys stay six feet away
you know yeah but so yeah that's crazy
that uh so you went to karate cut my mom
was too afraid I'd get bigger than her
and start fighting her Wow
oh my god that's almost like a UH you're
seeing cats masive stable or something
you know like a story from the past cats
mom that the child gets big enough and
that's why you keep them away from foods
that are healthy or keep them away from
opportunity and you're afraid you're
gonna overtake you mmm it's like that
movie where they made the girl have the
disease you know where they put gasoline
in her soup or something you know you're
talking about Mommy Dearest Mommy
Dearest fantasti is it like that cat was
your mom like Mommie Dearest no it was
something else it wasn't quite that
though your mom's more like the warden
Shawshank I feel yes and your Andy
Dufresne innocent but you still got to
play by the rules damn good job mm-hmm
we should do a reenactment recap does
indeed ooh frame and then who are we huh
then who are you you won't be the head
[ __ ] no I'm the man who gets that
look on his face when he realizes that
he that you tricked him out with the
taxes and stuff
oh that's the warden the warden yeah
well she's a nerd afraid I'll be read
okay you be read I'm Brooks was here you
know Brooks is here uh I can't work at
the market I'm gonna kill myself
let me carve my name into the [ __ ]
wall real yeah a little bit of vandalism
on the way out there like the old man
was gangster what else you got Nate huh
I can't believe Cadiz has been almost
imprisoned really mm-hmm
and you crawl through some [ __ ] like a
NIDA frame here you are doing here and
this is your Sam what the Nia
yes yes there's no ocean and there's no
boat actually chilling on your boat and
there's no end in the beginning here
that were to say white nail Brown oh I'm
sorry
my
I saved my sick days for the first two
days March Madness every year like I
really nodded as six year old I knew one
day I did love some some pools but I
just loved those first two games first
ago that is true since the day that that
morning that morning games it started
Tanana and Wisconsin was always only in
the first two rounds - so every year you
had to be there they lost to a Steph
Curry in like 2005 in the first round he
upset him they lost a shaman ah they've
lost you a lot would you miss y'all made
it to the finals in like 2015 yeah that
was actually my first year in LA I was
living in my car yeah great great times
yeah would you bet would you do chin did
you miss school for anything
did I miss school for anything yeah you
pretend you're sick ditch um maybe once
in a while just to do like houseboy yo
damn y'all some [ __ ] man yeah it was
it was so hard to get back into school
and sign this like fake signature this
yellow slip you gotta make a look you
know appropriate I don't want to deal
with it we used to pay a guy actually
and this guy was African American we pay
him to come check us out oh yeah twelve
fifteen dollars to be very few Sachin in
high school it's kind of hard for him to
blend in and sneak back in somewhere
being three we don't sneak in just turn
your sick and don't go in at all yeah
you fake your pinwheel no I mean the
next day you have to fill out this form
yeah they like you know no yeah yeah at
all she just had to tell him why you
weren't there yeah easy or not and the
lady would believe you or not and we
said the sickroom too but only had one
bed in it did say you at school if you
pretended you were sick you would go in
there but then one of your buddies
sometimes was already in there
masturbate my friend Bo was in there and
he knows who he is do I think he listens
to this shot it worked out for him you
know
oh it's worked out for him many a times
dude many times he cut that hand fever
what up King in this thing
this is Brennan from Lafayette Louisiana
I got a [ __ ] debate club when you
park do you back into the place or do
you pull in like a normal [ __ ] purse
I mean I think if you're robbing
something for you or stealing or you are
doing adultery you back in yeah just
need to get out fast yeah there you go
but I pull in like your goddamn tanks
every time front dog do you yeah
dude I'm not trying to steal anything
you look ridiculous with the bandana I
know it is and you have the right to
look ridiculous and I respect that
thank you I'm sorry man I said actually
pulling up a tic-tac of Theo's no no
talk for them kids is this back in what
do you guys do you back in or what do
you do back in evaluated for six years
oh you drove LA yeah really you ever
ding the cars and [ __ ]
no I was good sometimes I'm boys of the
Comba store ding the the doors and oh
yeah park your [ __ ] yeah remember
they're just it was a college trying to
make it they know how to drive cars yes
suddenly back like oh because this guy
can do riddles and stuff he can do it
most people about a drive stick either
which is shocking to me to like we're
learning anymore so what was your big
move what well how would you save time
really what do you mean when you how
would you save time when you were valet
yeah we bet we back them all in really
yeah that was the quickest really I'd
say so
see man I think if you have that type of
work ethic and ability you got to get
into this so that's where I was going
with this take the same confidence you
have with backing in cars to your
barbecue business students guys serenity
in back that recipe
the cattle brother yeah get a cattle get
a two-weeks give me a chance
okay I'll people jump up but look we
gave you one week and you bought a gold
chain so I feel you bro I respect it
it's a very Brendan style way to do
things you've learned from your sensei I
get it but the second week right you
gotta go this was a theater stick talk
that went over a million that's your car
bro oh my know that look like something
you get out of a happy meal do per
second I thought that was stuff on me I
was like can I do like that's a handsome
dude man that's a dope ass ride yeah
this back in America was normal yeah
that's when we were living remember that
when America was normal ah remember
never was nice when you didn't see a
newborn with a damn face plug on him
shut up culture corner from Las Vegas I
joined the circus early I'm a street
performer on the strip I do live art
what do you think about street
performers King under sting it people
that pretty much work without a captive
audience for tips or do dance music
really anything I mean what you think
Gang Gang huh
Machine Gun Kelly that's that Street
version that's an alley cat version
Machine Gun Kelly son TIG Notaro he's
funnier wow so lucky we got to support
this man's art a few out there you see
that man small right street art I think
this huh I think it's easier if it's not
rain and I think you see somebody doing
it in the rain you gotta buy it I agree
mmm I think it's dope to it and now in
Venice there's only so many houses it's
hard to figure out what's good what's
[ __ ] someone who's kind of a
journeyman cuz if you remember there's
the one-man band down there he literally
played nine instruments at a time
there's the duty walk on glass
those dude who swallowed swords yeah
yeah then they got those painters
there's the electric guy think he passed
away yeah now him he is on rollerblades
played electric guitar yeah you got a
you got I don't know if he did have a
Ghassan polar skates do with no pants on
dude there'd be a 50% chance I would you
know you'd catch something give me an H
I you know and that guy that guy left no
contact info but his name is Dawes
Jurina well we know where he's at though
you know mm-hmm so he's on the strip out
there so I think street performers I
like it I don't like it though when it
gets to the point where they're wasting
my time the dancers you know I don't
like when they put the pressure on you
like come on come on closer everybody
come on close don't be all the way out
there and then they give you the Hat
putting money like yeah damn dude or
they take a little six-year-old girl out
there and she's in a coma or something
and they just set her by Mike and
they'll put on like a like up previously
recorded things and then it's happened
be like that you're like what [ __ ] dude
like that kind of sits too much they're
bad they're bad right but it's not like
don't trick me out of my money like you
still got to be you know I respect the
hustle and then the talent so yeah I
respect the hustle but you can't don't
just try to you know put somebody out
there that's dead or something and be
like oh you know give us your money yeah
listen to this Tina Turner while you
look at freaking Ronnie he's dead you
know I'm not giving a dollar to that but
I hate it when they dancer guys make you
it takes so long what I'm saying
like the build-up to real [ __ ] tease for
about and now yeah do you want everybody
getting closer than they do a little
thing like oh not yet and then everybody
closer closer you over there I know you
enjoyed yourself I'm just trying that
your robot yeah okay nice to be on Third
Street dang I like it thanks man that's
good
and I got that hoodie on to this week
man oh don't touch me but keep that back
cash shop hoodie the back is nice I got
that limited range of potion baby a bad
spell casts bad spells what else here's
a guy right here who has a child with
him it looks like let's see what they're
up to in the last pocket has Brennan
talked about how he broke his thumb in a
fight well I broke my fourth and fifth
metacarpal in a fight had to get a plate
on it so king of sting it winning a
fight but breaking your hand becoming a
cyborg getting that titanium hitter
uh-oh
anyway Gang Gang break bones oh I love
it tell about that Wolverine son welcome
to the club
yeah that sounds like he did it on the
streets which was never encouraged yeah
yeah like he's freelance MMA do you have
you have any surgery you have to get
metal in no no one in here huh it's some
serious [ __ ] when they do it when it
rains my [ __ ] hurts does it really never
gets cold it hurts worse like pins and
no way really knocks that's like that
was an old person thing nah
Wolverine makes it seem all cool and
[ __ ] but it ain't cool man do you have a
hard time going through metal detectors
no it never goes off in that way huh
weird I bet you could probably roll dice
a little better you know I'm saying is
it you've like have any power in it any
extra different vibe in it mmm I wish
remember that movie was that movie with
the kid who broke his arm but they could
throw barrels yeah yeah Rookie of the
Year played for the Chicago Cubs yeah
who was in that movie some young Thomas
I don't think using a famous actor just
didn't he go to American Pie later
Thomas Ian Nicholas Gary Busey no time
Jay busi was the the other player on his
TV not busi almost did I almost got it
put in a movie with this guy Tommy
senior Nikolas oh he's uh what was a
movie mom remember American Pie one two
or three no no no later than that dude
it was like humble pie Stefan dude it
was sophomore slump it was like a low it
was not gonna be like a super high
budget movie do you want a good fourth
of July movie American Pie - really yeah
for the summer they go they go on a
little vacation they get summer jobs no
it sounds horrible oh you never seen
them breaking pies uh-oh
all three fantastic American Wedding I
gotta watch a lot of stuff what's it and
walk the line I need to watching it walk
hard hard Dewey Cox I heard that's good
well the real walk hard with Joaquin
Phoenix let's walk the line that's the
Johnny Cash biopic biopic or biopic um I
agree this looks like some Ultimate
Fighter contestant just lost something
at least wannabe hey Brandon a gold King
hosting it for your shower pendens UK
grandma from London or do you think of
brands then hot fire - is this is meant
to be an anarchy a but I got it facing
the wrong direction by accident that's
your name France Gang Gang London buzz
gang boy Sheffield Rock what's up I'll
be out there soon
shout out Sheffield bow shout out Sussex
oh you know okay
Liverpool Stroud shut up Manchester new
shot up West Staines bro eat any stains
what you know about that Sunderland son
uh-huh you don't know [ __ ] this new song
by getting burned instead again tap shut
out York Sunderland Stoughton Jeffries
yeah yeah that's what's turning Jeffries
is from mm-hmm
shout out York dude from I always say me
I'm thicker though dude I'd like a lot
more cream and I don't things I think
they're perfectly if you don't have time
to brush your teeth I have a york
peppermint pattie
that's fair same thing do they still
make them huh why don't they ever make
them thicker I can't be the only one who
wishes there's more cream in those write
another letter did I'd love have the
original letters burner for two places
oh my god Andy Dufresne Yeah right into
the library eventually they come oh come
on guys
half inch of thickness you guys got the
wrong idea man
come on I was just happening [ __ ] brands
do you know better to hurt to get
[ __ ] brands like a cow on your arm
son mm-hmm did people on your football
team do it yeah it's definitely well
what do you know about a spot in a black
shirt you like in the forums like
fraternities yeah they do they go Megan
pi5 do you have any friends that have
ever had it no I don't know anyone
that's got it my dad's got a stab wound
yes be that out boy he made it out but I
guess I wonder how they do that if
there's an it yeah yeah there's one
right there
that's not Omega and then they do is do
this yeah okay Brendan suey
you don't say that yeah we're gonna win
read the missing member of
chuck-e-cheeses band I think we both do
Bravo my [ __ ] looks height dude I posted
a young picture of me on my Instagram
and someone said I look like the Chuck E
Cheese red the originals were real
ratchet I made out of carpet where they
[Laughter]
you hearing what what are you
right there right there right there
David Lucas something you've run into
them chomping you got a do barbecue now
no right yeah
what were those books to where we all
reading those are fake books that's just
why people keep great reference an apple
because there's an apple if you move
down to right there that's the gap to
goblin right there baby that's my NICU
gargoyle I don't know yeah now let's see
the animal they're referencing that
Chucky to you that busted ass Chucky
Cheese I [ __ ] hate Chuck E Cheese yeah
but you know they're my bankruptcy
yeah yeah somebody will bail them out
there yeah maybe you two should know
forget that zoo in Sinaloa bill boom oh
yeah I could do one establishment but
I'm not getting into a whole chain of it
I'd rather do one food truck arrest is
ours
yeah we're gonna do that that pokey
truck I mean [ __ ] was fantastic it'd be
fun to have a food truck
look at that [ __ ] white pull up that
one I think that's the closest there's
been a lot of Chuckies over the years
too he started out really different you
heard the origin story of tricky oh
there he is right there we go to the
right neck a little bit no with your
mouse laugh right there oh yes Brian
towns eyes a positive energy you know
yeah yeah brah have you ever heard of
the Chucky Cheese origin story mmm the
the owner of Chucky Cheese came out and
gave the origin story you know Chucky
Cheese was developed he decided to throw
parties for kids cuz he didn't have any
friends mmm
it's the only way he could get kids to
play with us by selling parties Wow
and the e stands for entertainment
Charles entertainment cheese facts mom
yep it's hard in San Jose cat I think no
it started in New York oh I don't know
where it started they had a big one
yeah they had like a three-story one Wow
Wow
damn years ago bro now this this we may
have to cut out of the YouTube and
direct people to cliffs channel but we
talked about like 1990 sitcoms and stuff
and someone did an incredible intro of
King and staying in style of 1996 oh wow
to matchbox 120
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that was great discuss about
4,000 guys you can go watch out on the
clip you want you all know what we just
really enjoyed but you definitely it's
too bad we can leave that in and close
up the episode no that's all right man
well look I want to say happy 4th of
July
I'm glad that we all live in this
country you know glad we all live in a
place where we can do a show like this
and for right now yeah yeah and all have
jobs and stuff and we'll see Kevin
governor Newsom I try and shut this [ __ ]
down you think right he's that and now
you ain't gonna do [ __ ] we'll get
through it man we'll get through it
we're almost do the worst yeah yeah at
least we have each other you know a
member I love you guys love you guys for
happy 4th day and for go lights and
blackcats
yeah and that's not a racial thing
[Laughter]
fighter and wait I gotta go in and go
hard in the paint I do not think
and flows like rifle coffee I'm ready to
go I need a sponsor I am a monster about
to open up with this at my concerts flow
is contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
movie like I'm fresh off keto see a red
like Andrew Santino every something it
is like the great Bambino I'm 1/8 the
case oh and a case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine
hey Tommy I got a pack of matches in his
pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
traffic couldn't beat em quit playin
like that's in DoDEA's you don't want
the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feeling incredible grit and Sun him
me up he said it's too loud in the club
can you pick me your sting
beasting Rat King
and a stinking honesty beez in the trap
got the cheese on a string
and the sting king and the stinking and
the sting bee sting Rat King
and the stink-eye King an estate gotta
beez in the trap gotta cheese on a
strong
[Music]